ça c'est un peu c'est comme chez moi en
fait c'est chez moi c'est chez vous
complètement
à Yaoundé au Cameroun c'est votre
environnement donc au quotidien
désormais
c'est ça vous habitez dans une de ces
vous habitez dans une de ces cases voilà
c'est vrai c'est la route
sur le village
quel endroit incroyable
c'est bien foutu hein
je vous pose une question défendue vous
voulez bien
vous étiez plus heureux en gagnant à
Roland-Garros ou en chantant au Stade de
France
ce n'est pas comparable ce n'est pas
comparable
le gagnant Roland Garros c'était le rêve
de toute la première partie de ma vie
c'était mon rêve d'enfant c'est
important de vivre et aller au bout de
ses rêves d'enfants je rêvais de ça mais
il y avait aussi attaché à ça je pensais
qu'en arrivant au bout de ce rêve là je
c’était bon la vie c'était terminée
j'allais être heureux pour le reste de
ma vie et ça c'était une un moment d'une
puissance
inégalée jusqu'à présent à savoir que
c'est seconde qui qui
qui suivent le moment où vous voyez la
balle de match sortir et que vous tout
d'un coup ce rêve c'est 20 ans tout d'un
coup de travail en quelques secondes
c'est tellement puissant c'est tellement
fort c'est tellement beau et puis vous
vive ce moment avec
toute la famille tous les amis
[Musique]
tous les gens qui ont compté pour moi
c'était un endroit parfait c'est un
moment parfait ouais ça c'est Arthur mon
premier héros
lorsqu'il m'a rencontré
improbable parce qu'il faut raconter un
tout petit peu téléspectateurs si vous
me permettez d'abord il est vainqueur de
trois tournois du Grand Chelem c'est
déjà une légende du tennis et puis il
est en déplacement au Cameroun à Yaoundé
vous vous avez 11 ans vous avez quand
même assez peu de chance à priori de
tomber l'un sur l'autre pour autant
c'est ce qui va se passer vous allez
même jouer en fait de lui oui quand ils
font les exhibitions le soir la
tradition veut qu'on y joue l'après-midi
avec les gamins du coin ils appellent un
clinique et moi j'étais le petit gamin
du coin et je on dit Arthur H arrive au
club c'était comme un
rêve éveillé
et quand il est arrivé ça a été instant
c'était c'était foudroyant en fait
c'était comme mon grand frère mon Dieu
et de mettre qui vous repère d'ailleurs
qui sent tout de suite le potentiel je
joue avec vous
avec lui je tape des balles et ouais je
touche ma bille
mais c'est amusant parce que je
t'ai un bébé mais je savais que c'était
un moment important de ma vie c'est
c'est fou je sentais qui se passait
quelque chose de ce moment là j'ai cru
en mes rêves j'ai cru en mes rêves
et le rêve se prolonge parce que sept
ans plus tard vous retrouvez à Wimbledon
en double ce qui est quand même
surréaliste ou presque voilà cette image
on voudrait raconter ça
oui dans un film ça serait trop ce
champion vous voyez il a toujours la
même raquette et ce champion qui qui va
en Afrique il rencontre ce petit môme il
le fait venir s'entraîner et quelques
années après 7 ans après il joue sur le
grand stade du monde quels ont été vos
mots l'un pour l'autre à ce moment-là
quelles ont été ces mots pour vous
juste avant le match je pouvais pas
jouer je tremblais trop
et j'ai demandé à ce que c'est possible
de pas jouer c'était trop pour moi
c'était trop de trop d'émotions j'ai eu
très peur et je lui ai dit est-ce que
c'est possible de pas jouer
et maintenant
vous je crois que vous avez intégré la
cellule le préparation mentale à la
Fédée depuis quelques mois pour avoir un
vainqueur dans les 10 ans qu'est-ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui 40 ans qu'aucun
français n'a remporté de Grand Chelem
déjà c'est pas mal d'être cinquième
mondial vous savez quand vous jouez au
tennis un sport professionnel c'est pas
mal on n'est pas on n'a pas un pays on
n'a pas de culture de la gagne en France
le tennis c'est encore un sport de
loisirs quoi qu'on dise vous allez dans
les clubs c'est plus du loisir vous
voyez bien que dès qu'il y a un joueur
qui gagne la première chose qu'on fait
c'est essayer de le descendre et c'était
on n'a pas cette culture donc c'est
c'est pas parce que les joueurs sont pas
suffisamment forts mais le parcours pour
un joueur français pour un v5e mondial
il est au moins si dur que pour un
espagnol pour arriver deuxième c'est pas
du tout la même chose il y a pas la même
culture donc c'est peut-être ça qu'il
faut changer parce que changer un revers
c'est facile mais changer les mentalités
alors ça aurait été ça a commencé par
les joueurs les familles les entourages
les coachs les médias voilà c'est c'est
un lien c'est pas si simple que ça juste
un mot de tennis justement pour y rester
deux secondes fédérer Nadal qui se
tiennent la main en pleurant après leur
dernier match l'image a fait le tour du
monde vous l'avez vu j'imagine vous
pensez qu'il va de Lendl il a pleuré
quand vous avez arrêté votre carrière
non ça n'a aucun intérêt mais par contre
c'était tellement cette image ça m'a
fait tellement plaisir de voir cette
image je pense que c'est je pense ce que
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait depuis joli bon
ils ont fait des matchs extraordinaires
évidemment mais ce moment c'était tout
d'un coup j'ai enfin je vois l'humanité
de Roger enfin je vois l'humanité de
Rafa c'est pas à moi que vous allez je
vois c'est pas moi qui va vous dire que
le jeu de Sega est
incroyablement extraordinaire c'est pas
ça mais c'est des fois ça me manque
c'est l'être humain c'est gala que que
Roger un petit peu mais que je connais
en dehors mais c'est tellement bon de
voir ce côté humain quoi